مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في موجز الانباء من
قناه الجزيره اكدت مصادر الاسرائيليه ان
جنود الاحتلال قتلوا رميا بالرصاص سائقه
سياره فلسطينيه بعد تنفيذه عمليه دهس
استهدفت عددا من الجنود عند مدخل بلده بيت
امر شمال مدينه الخليل افادت وسائل اعلام
الاسرائيليه ان الثلاثه جنود اصيبوا بجروح
اثر تعرضهم للدهس وقالت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان منفذ العمليه هو ضابط في
احد الاجهزه الامنيه التابعه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه بجانبها قالت مصادر فلسطينيه
غير رسميه ان منفذ عمليه دهس هو محمد
بردعيه وهو ضابط في جهاز الاستخبارات
العسكريه من بلده صوريف شمال الخليل
شددت اطرافه العمليه السياسيه في السودان
على ضروره حسم الخلافات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع بشان الدمج والتسريح في مده
اقصاها اسبوع واكد خالد يوسف المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه اتفاق القوه المدنيه
والعسكريه على مضاعفه الجهود للتجاوز
العقبه المتبقيه تمهيدا لتوقيع الاتفاق
النهائي واضاف ان الطرفين اتفقا ايضا على
تحديد السادس من الشهر الجاري للتوقيع
عليه
وزير الدفاع عن الرئيس على مضاعفه المجمع
الصناعيه العسكري الروسيه لانتاج كل انواع
الاسلحه التقليديه وعاليه الدقه وبحث
القضايا المتعلقه بتحسين كفاءه النظام
اللوجي لتزويد القوات بكل ما هو ضروري من
الاسلحه والذخائر
مع اشتداد المعارك في محوري خرسون
وزباروجيا نشرت الكتيبه الهجوميه في لواء
مشاه البحريه مشاهد من مواجهات مباشره بين
قوات اوكرانيه وروسيه في احد محاور القتال
بمنطقه دنيا
مسافه قريبه بين مجموعه هجوميه اوكرانيه
ومجموعه الروسيه
بعد تسلم روسيا رئاسه مجلس الامن لمده شهر
قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان رئاسه روسيا
للمجلس دليل على افلاسه الاجراءات في
المؤسسات الدوليه من جهته قال وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني لبلاده تعتبر تولي
روسيا رئاسه المجلس صفعه في وجه المجتمع
الدولي
نقلت وكاله وصشيته عن مصادر مطلعه قولها
ان رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يواجه تهمه جنائيه واحده على الاقل في
لائحه الاتهام التي اقرتها هيئه محلفين في
منهات اوضحت الوكاله ان رئيس السابق يواجه
تهمه متعدده اخرى بتزوير السجلات تجاريه
سيكشف عنها عندما يسلم نفسه يوم الثلاثاء
المقبل
ونقلت وكاله مصدر مطلع قوله ان فريق ترامب
القانونيه
الرئيس السابق الجنائيه الى
بحسب المصدر فان هذه الخطوه تاتي سبب ما
خوف الفريق بان ترامب لن يحصل على محاكمه
عادله في
انتهى هذا المجلس في امان الله